ان القوات المسلحه اليمنيه مستمره في منع
السفن الاسرائيليه في البحر الاحمر الان
يجب ان اثبت للطرف الاخر انني لا ازال
افاوض من موقف القوه وكما قنا منذ البدايه
هدف اسرائيل هو استعاده كل الرها الجيش
العبري يتاهب لاجتياح جنوب القطاع وواشنطن
تحذر البحريه الامريكيه تسقط طائره يمنيه
وخطه امريكيه لدعم عدد من الدول العربيه
ما السبب الحكومه العبريه توسع توزيع
السلاح على مواطنيها تلبيب تغازل حلفاء في
الكونغرس الامريكي وواشنطن توجه اصابع
الاتهام نحو تركيا بشان القطاع الصين
تبتكر صاروخا يمكن اعاده استخدامه
الخارجيه الالمانيه انخفاض الاهتمام
بالنزاع في اوكرانيا قاتل جزء كبير من
الدعم الامريكي لنظام كيف لا يصل الى
اوكرانيا هنجاريا ترفض انضمام اوكرانيا
للاتحاد الاوروبي بشكل مباشر عوده المعارك
بعد تمديد الهدنه ليوم واحد لا وقت تضيعه
تل ابيب حيث ذكرت صحيفه ياد عوت احرنوت ان
رئيس اركان الجيش العبري رتسي هاليفي صادق
على خطط لمواصله القتال والمناورات البريه
في القطاع فيما قال الجيش العبري ان
الهدنه الانسانيه ستستمر في ضوء جهود
الوسطاء لاطلاق سراح المزيد من الاسرى
ليؤكد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني
بلينكن خلال لقائه النتنياهو على ضروره
حمايه المدنيين الجنوبي القطاع اذا استؤنف
القتال هناك بعد الهدنه المعلنه حاليا كما
افادت وسائل اعلام غربيه بان واشنطن وتل
ابيب تجريان محادثات منذ عده اسابيع حول
عمليه محتمله للجيش العبري في جنوب القطاع
في حين لم تعطي واشنطن بعد موافقتها
النهائيه على تنفيذها بالمقابل كشفت صحيفه
بوليتيكو نقلا عن مسؤولين امريكيين ان تل
ابيب خفضت عدد قواتها البريه المشاركه في
المرحله الاولى من العمليه البريه تحت ضغط
من واشنطن بدوره عد نتنياهو ليقول ان
حكومته ستواصل توسيع توزيع السلاح على
المواطنين مضيفا ان هذا الاجراء يثبت
جدواه في الحرب فيما افاد موقع اكسيوس بان
قاده من الجيش العب اجر سلسله محادثات مع
نواب ديمقراطيين في الكونجرس بشان حرب
القطاع وتاتي هذه اللقاءات في خضم خلاف
وسط صفوف الديمقراطيين بشان ربط المساعدات
لتل ابيب بشروط واضحه من جانبها ذكرت
وسائل اعلام امريكي ان الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن ابدا قلقه لنتنياهو بشان هجوم للجيش
العبري مرتقب في جنوب القطاع وطالبه بايدن
بتوخي الحذر بسبب الكثافه السكانيه
العاليه في الجنوب وعدم باستخدام نفس
القوه التدميريه التي نفذتها القوات
العبريه في شمال القطاع هناك قال مساعد
وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه لشؤون الارهاب
والاستخبارات الماليه براين نيلسون ان
تركيا لعبت دورا بارزا في مخططات تمويل
الفصائل هذا وكشفت صحيفه اسرائيل يوم عن
خطه جديده يعدها الكونجرس الامريكي تربط
بين تقديم مساعدات ماليه كبيره لعدد من
الدول العربيه على راسها مصر مقابل قبول
لاجئين من القطاع ميدانيا وبرغم الهدنه
فقد افادت وكاله وفا بان القوات العبريه
اقتحمت مدينه ومخيم طولكرم شمال غربي
الضفه الغربيه وكذلك مدينه طوباس شمال
شرقي الضفه وقتلت شابا في بيتونيا فيما
قصفت زوارق حربيه عبريه ساحل خانيونس جنوب
القطاع بقذائف صاروخيه ليعلن الجيش العبري
اطلاق النار واصابه سائق سياره في الاغوار
حاول دهس جنود على حاجز عسكري لننتقل الى
اليمن حيث اعلن مسؤول امريكي ان سفينه
حربيه تابعه للبحريه الامريكيه اسقطت
طائره مسيره اطلقت من اليمن قرب مضيق باب
المندب في احدث حلقه من سلسله تهديدات
الحوثيين بحسب سبوتنيك بالعوده الى
الولايات المتحده وبعد وفاه ثعل بالسياسه
الامريكيه هنري كاسنر اشهر وزير خارجيه
امريكي عن عمر ناهز 100 عام بعد مسيره
دبلوماسيه وسياسيه حافله استمرت لعقود قال
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي دمتري
ميدفيدف ان كيسنجر كان ياخذ الحقائق في
الاعتبار ولم يتبع فقط شرائع السياسه
الامريكيه مضيفا الان لا يوجد اي اثر
لاشخاص مثله في الاداره الامريكيه وفي
العالم الغربي في الصين افادت وسائل اعلام
داخليه ان بكين تجهز لاطلاق اول صاروخ
فضائي طورته ليكون قابلا للاستخدام عده
مرات واضافت صحيفه صينيه ان الاطلاق الاول
لصاروخ ينجون الصيني القابل لاعاده
الاستخدام من المفترض لان يتم عام
2024 من مقاطعه هاين جنوبي الصين تحفيز
الماني بعد كل المعطيات من الدول الغربيه
هل صارت اوكرانيا وحيده لتجيب وزيره
الخارجيه الالمانيه انالينا بربوك بان
انخفاض الاهتمام بالنزاع في اوكرانيا قد
يؤدي الى عواقب سلبيه ودعت الدول الغربيه
الى بذل كل ما في وسعها لدعم نظام كيف
مضيفه ان انخفاض الاهتمام بالنزاع في
اوكرانيا قاتل في المقابل افادت صحيفه
واشنطن بوست بان جزء كبيرا من الاموال
الامريكيه المخصصه للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه لا يصل فعليا الى اوكرانيا
واشارت المقاله الى ان الاموال لا يتم
ارسالها مباشره الى اوكرانيا بل تستخدم في
الولايات المتحده لتطوير اسلحه جديده او
استبدال الاسلحه التي تم ارسالها الى كيف
هنا اكد رئيس مكتب رئيس الوزراء المجري
رجيلي جولياس بان بلده ليس مستعدا لدعم
التغييرات في ميزانيه الاتحاد الاوروبي
وقبول اوكرانيا في الاتحاد لانه من الواضح
انه لم تتم معالجه كلت القضيتين بشكل صحيح
ليصرح الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي
انه يشعر بالقلق لان بلاده اصبحت خارج
دائره التركيز بسبب الاحداث في الشرق
الاوسط وبشان الحرب اضاف زيلينسكي انه
سيكون من الصعب استعاده دونباس اكثر من
شبه جزيره القرم لكن وسائل الاعلام اشارت
الى ان زيلنسكي اكد مره اخرى انه لن يوافق
على هدنه قبل ان تسحب روسيا قواتها في
الميدان استهدفت القوات الروسيه معدات
وجنود القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه في مصنع
افدي فكا للكيماويات فيما افادت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه بان الجيش الاوكراني خسر
نحو 750 عسكريا على محاور القتال الاساسيه
خلال 24 ساعه بعيدا عن اجواء المعارك صرحت
المتحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
ماريا زخروف ان المنطقه السائده في منظمه
الامن والتعاون في اوروبا يؤكد استحاله
مناقشه مصير القاره الاوروبيه دون روسيا
مضيفه ان موسكو ترى حضور لافروف اجتماع
وزراء خارجيه منظمه الامن والتعاون في
اوروبا فرصه للمنظمه ذاتها لعدم الانجرار
نحو الهاويه